hey welcome to a new project camp update
in the previous video you could see us
looking for a location for our yoga
decks and in this video we're gonna
build them and install them on three
very beautiful locations was gonna have
a little interview with wautr and debbie
that built the decks
and we're gonna have a look at our water
system because we wanted to make it
drinkable to see how that's gonna go
but for now the wood arrived so let's
start building decks
[Music]
as you can see we got already the wood
or then a part of the wood the pine wood
uh
it took a bit longer so we hope the next
will be
the next week
so it's still a bit
wet and it's like
really heavy
and it's also a bit tricky with the wet
wood because it can still move a lot
but yeah this is what we got and we have
to work with it so
see how it turns out
we're going to build a platform in the
whole the whole deck we're going to make
it here in base camp because we have the
big miter saw
and other handy tools so to make it
first and then place it on the mountain
i made
a nice
way to mark all the beams
and this is also how we're going to make
it
i i wrote down the the numbers
going to cut them for the shape it's
important they have the the right number
on the right place
so we make it according this
structure and then when we made it here
we can easily
deconstruct it take it up the mountain
and reconstruct it
so
to keep it all a bit simpler
don't fall down
[Music]
do
[Music]
right to make it a solid structure of
the base
we connect all the big beams with the
displays of multiplex
is something like this
we still have to
balance all the beams a bit
and then we lift them
drill big holes through it
cut a bit out for beams here so it sinks
knives in it
and later on we put all the planks like
this
so then it's nice when it's an even
surface
i will now put them in the perfect right
position
and then when everything is ready
we drill big holes through it
to connect it all together with these
big rods
and then it should make a solid
structure
to carry the load of all the planks
good
it turned out all the beams were
of a bit different sizes
it's pretty rough rough cut so i know
now
took out a bit of the top
to fit the base plate and i also take a
bit out of the bottom so they're all the
same height
and we can make a nice tight
fix
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
that's cool
good to see it finally
[Applause]
all right
end of the week one deck finished for
now
ready to take somewhere to a nice place
it was quite challenging with the
bending and the twisting wood it was
pretty wet
and we also find some things in the
design that were a
bit
a practical building wise or a bit
not too solid construction wise
so
we'll update
the design a bit and more about this in
the next videos
okay
now beer
hey you're here for adventure it's a bit
too late i think when you can see the
teeth yeah that's true
like if you do like this
meanwhile we got visited by a new friend
she just dropped by and disappeared
again maybe some of you guys know who
she is if so just write it down in the
comments
[Music]
okay the first deck is finished now we
just have to disassemble it bring it to
its final position and build it up again
then we build the other two decks
disassemble them as well and bring them
to their final position
last step
sand and oil all of them and we're
already done shouldn't take too long
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so today we're going to look into an
upgrade for our water system because up
until now all the water we have comes
from this well
which has been working great and we use
it for cooking showering and it's
basically our water so this pumps it to
the base camp where we use it
but up until now we were not able yet to
use it for drinking because and when we
did some water tests
it was good in terms of the amount of
minerals inside or heavy metals but the
amount of bacterias in there were too
high for drinking so up until now we've
been always getting our water from a
local little fountain but now today
we're going to make a little update to
make
our water drinkable
so here we have our water system uh
water comes from the well we just saw
pumps up and then it goes to the
filtering system two different filters
they only really filter on particles so
little pieces of sand or soil that are
filtered out but all the germs or
minerals would still be
in the water itself
so in order to really filter out those
things you have different kinds of
filters we looked into two potential
options one is collider silver which
filters it we find a pretty cool filter
that is made from sawdust wood
and soaked in colloidal silver so it
filters the water but it's sort of a
drip system so very slowly the water
comes out but the cool thing is it's
very low in maintenance
another filter system we found is a uv
light so you basically have a light of
uv and it kills all the bacteria and
germs inside
and because it has a bigger flow through
rate we decided to go for that one
so here we have our uv filter it's
pretty basic
and the water flows in on one side and
comes out on the other side
and inside of this tube you would have a
uv light
so this just shines and then kills
everything inside
uh only other thing we also need to
change is that you want to make sure
that there are no particles in the
in this area because it can give a shade
to everything below
and then it doesn't disinfect that water
so we need to change our filters as well
to 5 micron
to make sure there are no particles but
you can find more of this technical
information in the research module
for now we're going to install it right
here on the site and hook it up to make
sure that all the water in the kitchen
is drinkable and the shower and the
garden we keep
filtered
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so here we have the uv filter installed
and we've actually already been using it
for about a week because
we also send some tests to laboratory
and we got them back now
so the main thing we're looking at here
is the germs and the kodi forms so the
germs at 37 degrees before they were 60
and now 8
at 22 degrees above 100 and now 24 so
that's all good that's what we're going
for
however the coliforms actually went up
for some reason which is not good and
because of that actually now this
officially is not drinkable water
because the coliforms has to go down
it's a bit tricky because it can depend
on the time of the year the time of the
moment you measure the water so it's
sort of an ongoing process to make sure
you measure it correctly
um if you want to lower the coliforms i
think the next step would be putting in
chloride into the well in the system
which we also don't really like and some
people usually drink the water from the
wells so we're still a bit uh
not super sure what to do next so for
now i think we're just gonna test
drinking water i mean we've been doing
it for a week and we're all good
it shouldn't have a fact on the long
term that's more when there are heavy
metals inside and minerals so if we're
not get sick i guess we should be good
but we're still exploring this topic and
learning a lot about it so if you have
some comments about it make sure to go
to the research module because you can
follow step by step what we did and if
you have suggestions or input or no
better how to read tests let us know
then we can keep on proving it
but yeah for now this thing is just
cleaning the water
fresh water if i'm not here next week
it's probably because i of diarrhea
but yeah we'll keep an eye on this and
for now i'm going to show you the end
result of the yoga decks because they're
finished
the idea was to place the decks in three
totally different kind of surroundings
for the first one we chose the mimosa
forest right next to the camp
a close by and nicely shaded place which
is easy and fast to reach and can be
used for many activities since it's just
a few steps away from base camp
the second one we placed right on top of
the mountain which is a bit harder and
more difficult to reach since you have
to go a few steep pods and walk further
away from base camp
but it's really worth it
you have there the most incredible view
of the local area and can enjoy the
silence and loneliness of the place
best time to be there is for sunrise or
scented when the mountains on the other
side are dipped in bright colors
also watching the stars here can be a
great experience
we managed to place the deck without any
drilling in the stone
the shape of the rock holds it in place
the deck is big success because it's
already a popular hangout
and the last one we placed next to the
creek on the grass field underneath the
old cork tree
this is the oldest tree of the land
the place feels very grounded and is
connected to water
it has a special atmosphere and is good
for use in the summer because you can
dip into the cold fresh water of the
creek
[Music]
ok
welcome to our little interview
with the builders and designers of the
yoga deck
maybe you would like to introduce you to
the audience yeah
so please tell us who are you
where you're from
and
what do you do in project camp
i'm about to die from trailstrike
come from the netherlands
from around utrecht but
lived in several places
i'm a product designer and maker
carpenter
and i'm
like just like to make stuff
so that's broad
and i
am here to build the yoga decks
i'm devi
from holland as well but more from the
south i'm from bravant in between
tilburgh and
it's called it's a small village
and i'm a massage therapist and a yoga
teacher
now i'm a carpenter building also the
yoga decks
where do you know project came from and
how did you get here
a friend told us about the episode that
was on dutch television
where
this project and dave starred
and it was
we immediately felt
kind of connection like it was something
we were we were looking for
we already had the intention to do some
volunteering somewhere and this really
fits
our likes and
interests
for me as as product designer i find it
really interesting what uh
where this project is about or
designing a more sustainable way of
living instead of
designing stuff because the world is
full of stuff and we don't need any more
i
tend to think a lot
what do you usually do in life
so
usually i'm a yoga teacher and a massage
therapist
so i used to run my own business for
eight years and it was super nice
it got also very big maybe even a little
bit
too big and then i wanted to make it
simple again so now
we're traveling with our van and
[Music]
see what projects come up and sometimes
i work
in a completely different
thing
than what i studied for but
yeah i have my massage table with me i
have my yoga mats with me
and a giant tent
so i can work basically anywhere
last year
or last years
i worked
for myself as a carpenter
did a few renovations
and a
workshop where i worked on different
products
and also last year we worked a big time
on the van to build it
about three months
that was a lot of fun
so now we're ready for a new adventure
how was the building process of the yoga
decks for you
you really like to work on the joker
decks
also the
everybody really open for the ideas we
had
about the shape and
form and the size and where they should
come so
that gave a lot of motivation
uh it was interesting to work with
different materials but also a bit
challenging
the wood was not always straight and
so it was not always easy
it was also going a bit late sometimes
the delivery
other otherwise that i
use from the netherlands
but in the end we're super happy with
the results
it was nice to
place them to work somewhere on the
mountain or down at the creek just
with bird signs around you and
yeah the the results are really nice
super happy about it
and how long did it take you to finish
the decks in general
i think we were
here for eight weeks
and so
yeah and before we did not much research
actually um
we came quite open
so from the design and to
go to the wood
shop to
found out the different types of wood
and
finding the places
yeah
to place the decks
i think it took us yeah the eight weeks
you already mentioned that you use
eucalyptus for the for one of the decks
um
could you maybe tell us the reason for
that because it's an invasive species
and
um growing here all around and
um
yeah what is the reason for that
it seems to be a bit
uh contradictionary to use the
eucalyptus
because we don't like it there in
fire asset and the eclipse forests are
really like plantations nothing else
grows there
but there's also quite some eclipses
growing on the land
they say they have good properties
and to get a good judgment of if this
would on this land and maybe neighboring
land
in the future is useful
just needed to try it to get a better
idea
uh next question would be what are you
gonna do next after that because you're
gonna leave soon right
we're gonna leave even
today
yeah a few days before we arrived here
we found out i am pregnant
so i've been doing eight weeks of my
pregnancy here and now i'm 16 weeks
so we're gonna go back to holland for a
while and find a place to stay
for the baby
to be born
and then in the beginning of next year
we want to
get in the van again
and
hopefully the baby will like it
and otherwise otherwise she will
he she will learn to like she will learn
to like it
and we will yeah and we will hopefully
travel again yeah next year yeah
and maybe come back here because we
really like it yeah and maybe
for sure
so that's it
thank you very much you're welcome and
yeah have a good trip thank you
goodbye
[Laughter]
yeah
all right so that was it for this video
we just had our first snack here on the
yoga deck works good for that as well
wow and debbie are now
leaving so this is the last time you're
going to see them
make sure to remember their faces
and
if you already want to see the next
video make sure to support on patreon
and if not you'll just see us next week
same time same channel
bye